first thing you should do before
trimming your beard is give your face a
nice wash secondly you want to use
something to hydrate it you want to put
a little oil in there what I'm using
right here is our blue and black magic
oil and that will just soften the beard
up soften the skin when we're trimming
it it's going to give you that extra
Glide that you need we're going to take
down John's beard and we start with the
sideburns this is an important part
right here because you don't want to you
want it to blend into the hair that's
already there you don't want to go too
short so get into it and just use a nice
upward stroking motion just to blend
into the cyber ends that are there and
that seems to be working really nice
it's always good to make sure you
stretch the skin it just makes it a
little easier so take your other hand
and just give it a little bit of a
stretch so now that we got the desired
length or that we want we're gonna give
it a nice shape with the liner one
mistake that guys commonly make is they
cut into it too much don't go crazy
making these lines try to follow the
natural shape of the beard and the face
and keep things nice and natural so as
you can see his hair is pretty full from
here on so any of these little guys
we're just going to get into don't don't
approach it head-on like this and cut it
as we're going to get those hard lines
so approach it coming down and just edge
your way in a little bit so I'm gonna
put my machine on I'm just going to kind
of use my finger just to kind of give me
some control here lean against the face
and just make my line you can also just
use the corner of the machine just to
get the desire to line in there so now
that we have the length and the shape of
your summer beard we have one last step
and that's just to blend your beard in
with your sideburns
he's going to go over on both sides and
just give it a nice blend and what
that's going to do is just give it a
nice soft transition into the current
hair you have already there's your
summer beard